let's let's jump to this ubi thing I
want to ask I want to talk about I have
this let's let's do let's talk about
universal basic income and Starship
Troopers yeah have you ever seen
Starship Troopers yeah service gear
you've talked about a lot on the show
actually we have we service a lot huh
service guarantees citizenship yeah
basically oh there we go
so here's what I was getting to right so
in the previous segment we're talking
about you have a bunch of people who
refuse to read evidence who refuse to
watch videos and just want to be angry
and these people vote and that voting
impacts how society functions and they
vote for people who exploit their
unwillingness to actually read and
understand and engage so the example I
used was oppose someone who said like
someone sends him a video of like here's
Tim's opinion and they go let me stop
you right there
I don't need to watch a video it may
prove me wrong so I'm not gonna even
that it's like people oh that's in there
they're just their brains are closed
like I know I don't need no I don't need
anybody to show me anything I know and
the person goes in votes so that gets me
thinking like I'm for the most part not
in favor of the Starship Troopers
argument about service guarantee to
citizenship okay I think it's
interesting idea we're talking about or
just the simple right to vote if you
serve what do you mean well I mean it's
is one thing to become a citizen but
then oh you're citizen but then have the
ability to vote you know I know they're
not exactly the same thing and so for
those that aren't familiar with Starship
Troopers it's basically like everyone
has equal rights but only citizens vote
your so what are they called civilians
and citizens right okay is that what it
wasn't thinking man it's been too long
since I've seen this but and the book
apparently was like a lot better but
basically everywhere all the civilians
have equal rights free speech whatever
if you want to vote you have to sign up
for I think with it two years I think so
yeah and then after two years you become
a citizen and now you have you enjoy you
know the right to vote and run for
office and elect people and it's funny
because a lot of people on the Left have
claimed Starship Troopers is a model of
fascism where it's like you have to
serve the military before but I don't
think that's even true for this for the
book I think it was like civil
service not military service oh hi Lee
sure yeah I don't know I want to talk
about universal basic basic income but
I'll first ask you what do you think
about that idea
uh well I mean what do you what's what
would be a civil service
you know like working at the post office
or SDM you know DMV so working a regular
job that is in the government something
you know working on roads fixing roads
cleaning up the side of the highway like
what that kind of stuff
probably yeah I mean yes I'm like that
and and that could include military
service okay military service doesn't
mean combat as a lot of people don't
understand - they think it means you're
gonna go out the gun like that that's
that's actually the response I got from
Cameron caskey I don't know if you know
who he is he's one of the survivors from
parkland Hooda like yeah but you big
press he got a bunch of press after
parkland the Marlin shooting he's a cool
dude I really I think he's cool dude but
his response to me so here's what I said
here's what I said
what if universal basic income came with
mandatory civil service the army is
recruiting and they pay your bills and
college right
I wasn't saying everyone should have to
join the army in order to get universal
basic income I was making a point about
how there is an easy path to getting
government wages college health care and
join the army you know I mean sure one
example of a civil service his response
was let's throw free speech in there too
I have the right to speak if you haven't
almost been killed and there's a lot
wrong with with with his immediate
response it's like first of all yeah a
lot of people in the Army like desk
clerks you know I mean it's like you
know you know the the story of the
Covington kids mm-hmm the the kids were
standing on the steps of the Lincoln
Memorial
Oh an American's banging the drum you
were wearing Mogga hats yeah yeah okay
Native American guy was like I'm a
Vietnam era veteran he was a
refrigerator repairman in like Tulsa or
something okay yeah you know what said
he was in I don't know yeah he was just
like a refrigerator repairman people
seem to think that like joining the army
means they're like parachuting into
Afghanistan yeah Vietnam era because
because he didn't actually do anything
and he got like discharged I don't
happen to that guy but that's that's
like the immediate reaction people have
they assume like any service to the
government is like I don't know death
Patrol or something yeah so so for those
that aren't familiar with a universal
basic income as I assume most of you are
it's a guaranteed income from the
government so I asked a question
that's it I didn't say we should do it
this way it should be this way I was
like what if what if you be I was
mentally civil service meaning everybody
got a guaranteed wage and then you had
to do some kind of civil service for
some kind of period I didn't even say
what is it's a question I think that
would raise the general what's the term
looking for just respect for your land
and your your neighbor you know because
doing civil service you're helping
others
that's essentially what it is you know
so I feel a lot of people kind of lose
themselves in just maintaining their own
personal lives and they don't right they
don't let others affect them they don't
do they don't care about other people
they just do their own thing and that
tends to lead to things that people get
greedy
whatever I'm sure there's many different
ways but the more you help others the
the more empathy you gain and I think
that's a big problem with humans
nowadays for sure I think if there was
like we I think we used to have more
community-based programs and now
everything's fractured exactly yeah like
virtual yeah we need that back but
here's what I was thinking about it is
right I'm thinking about civil service
and universal basic income and what's
really funny is the resistance from
those who would typically support ubi
okay how dare you tell me I would have
to work to receive money it should be
all right are universal my in there we
go yeah okay
listen it should be a right to live for
free if you don't want to give why
should you get yeah so so the point I
made I'm on the other work is free
speech costs nothing burgers burgers
require human labor so should people
have to contribute in order to receive
if not then where do the burgers come
from if you have a hundred people and
100 of them are saying I would like a
burger but none of them want to work and
there's no burgers yeah
it's that simple so I was thinking like
Andrew Angus talked about universal
basic income being opt-in if you do you
forego other benefits right so it can
actually cut a lot of costs that does
make sense actually it doesn't
necessarily cover the total cost of ubi
okay however if not everybody signed up
for it then you might actually be able
to do it mm-hmm now the challenge I
guess is for one it's definitely a huge
government massive expansion of power
and authority and stuff like that for
sure it's a good point yeah definitely
but it is it's not necessarily bad if
it's run you know locally and
independently locally or something like
that mm-hmm
but regardless of the merit of whether
it's good bad the point is it makes
infinitely more sense that if the
government is gonna giving you money you
should do something for it in which case
it's just a national jobs program I mean
and then it's like the green so so but
i'll tell you what i familiar with the
green new deal a little bit yeah so it
was like you know guaranteed income for
those unwilling to work was one of the
things they put in their document that's
the one they pulled though right they
panic yeah yeah yeah so so Col de cortes
puts out a frequently asked questions
and it's like we're gonna give income to
people unwilling to work that's the
extent they go and I'm like isn't the
compromise just create like a federal
jobs program where what if we did like
bounties you know I mean like there
could be like a community center where
it like people who work in government
there could be a task required that have
a set budget and they would say here's a
job that needs to be done and then it
would pay a set rate and you could go in
and do a freelance government you know
contributions or civil service or
something hmm
yeah otherwise what we just give people
free stuff I mean you you someone can
mop a floor and someone could do a
terrible job mopping the floor I'm just
using mopping the floor as a random idea
but it's like not everyone's gonna do
the job well you know it's like they
could mop half the floor be like yeah I
did it sure give me my giving my income
now yeah it's clear you wanna hear
whatever you know right so in that case
you end up not actually get anything
done exactly then then the government's
spending money for people like yeah I
did the job and then it ends up being
like they didn't even do the job they
just clicked that they did it and then
they're getting paid and it's like
somebody actually responded with it that
they were like that what happens then is
the government hires a bunch of kids to
dig holes and a bunch of other kids to
fill the holes that they just dig yeah
they just dug exactly you want to hear
one of the crazier ideas that may be
crazy like Fox is paying people who
commit crimes hmm yeah
that's the punishment if you commit a
crime they give you money
huh yeah have you heard that I'm a very
good on scent at work the argument is
that it costs us like you know thirty
thirty thousand dollars a year to house
an inmate okay and if a lot of these
crimes are property crimes as the result
of proper poverty we're better off
giving them strict restrictions like you
got a check-in you got do these things
and then we'll give you cash paying
criminals not to commit crime is cheaper
than actually putting them in jail and
it actually stops the crime I like that
I mean why wouldn't we go into that
think about that that's because they
would encourage people to just become
criminals for income or not be criminals
I mean yeah that's no no you're right I
see what you're saying yeah so it's it's
it's people have these funny funny ideas
where you think about it you're like I
get it and then think about what that
means like oh yeah okay
no I get it you're right you're gonna
end up with like you know I heard
there's a meme about Scandinavians okay
I want to go to jail actually there's
it's funny that you say that because
there's a jail that's for sale in her
where her parents live and it's like
right in the middle of town and it's I'm
looking at the building it's beautiful
people they got TVs in the room
everyone's got a nice window on like the
third or fourth floor overlooking the
water you got to get context to her so
you can just lose my wife this is a this
is a small town in Sweden it's it's in
some islands so that it's like right in
the middle of an island it's right in
the entrance of the town and it's
beautiful I mean it's for sale it's like
a he could be in it like a dope Airbnb
but it's a jail but I'm looking and I'm
like that does not look like a jail like
all the rooms are fairly large yeah for
what you would expect a jail cell to
look like and like look like a cell so
interestingly one of the arguments for
universal basic income is that it would
reduce crime because it would reduce
poverty okay so it's interesting and I
see this this is one of the biggest
problems just people in general have yes
poverty breeds crime that doesn't
necessarily mean giving criminals money
will stop crime well that's kind of like
isn't that kind of like saying that if
you just give a homeless person house
you'll solve the problem I don't
actually see that solving the problem
because there might actually be some
underlying issues that aren't just yeah
I see another problem is we don't
even you know whatever class you're in
we're not teaching kids like about money
I didn't learn about money in in my
school so like and and especially
probably in these poverty areas they're
not like teaching like alright so if you
make some money don't just go buy stuff
you need to invest properly think about
what you need in your life
like this isn't something that we're
even talking about it's like that that
also is part of the problem you know
they get money from the government like
oh well go buy a new TV instead of you
need to use that for what you need to
use it for to pay a rent to make sure
you're eating food correctly furthering
yourself instead of just being part of
the system that they want that's what
they want this is why the question what
if is so important in any discussion
right that's why I tweeted what if I'm
not and you get a bunch of emotions
being thrown back at your anger and
people like because this is why I find
myself in a milquetoast offensive
sitting petition yeah dude there's so
much involved in what could happen and
what needs happen before any kind of
major overhaul of any kind of program no
one can predict or calculate so you sit
now the bunch of people you talk about
it and if eventually you say I think
we've covered as many bases as possible
let's do a trial run well there you go
if one person just comes out and demands
income for people unwilling to work it's
like dude you can't just throw a wrench
into a an engine you'll break it it's
not going to change it's like I think
this cog would go good here
smash especially when there's like
millions and millions and millions of
pieces to this engine which is the right
America you know and so that's grinding
and everything's going crazy
mm-hm but I just thought of something
when you mentioned at school what if
public schools paid kids for A's good
grades but it wasn't they just give them
cash they basically can buy things
within the school or give them credit
for sex college it's like school credits
like a future you know you're investing
in your future if you get all A's you're
gonna get a percentage off whatever
college you go to
no no that's that I don't I'm just
spitballing here and what I'm trying to
say is a school would have a local
commissary or something okay candy bars
you know so does bunches sure and the
school will say you know for every egg
you get an A test you earn five school
credits you know and
five school credits equivalent of $1 or
something okay then the kids actually
have an account they can look at their
accounts they can bounce their accounts
they can see what they can spend on they
can trade credits between each other
actually give them an understanding of
how money works how to save money
schools could have like an interest
system it's not real cash it's just like
the school could spend you know a
thousand bucks you know a month unlike a
and it could be pens and pencils and
erasers and staplers yeah things they
knew yep oh my god and then a kid could
be like you know I got an a on every
test in my class now I can go get that
you know candy bar I wanted I like that
make them actually work and get some
benefit from their work and understand
the real value of work and what they can
buy with it instead what do we do we put
kids in institutionalized learning
facilities where everything is provided
for them yeah and then finally by the
time they graduate with their degree at
22 after college they're like tell me
what to do boss what do I do boss why
isn't the government to do this to do
your job yeah this is why I hired you
know for communism right because they're
like my entire existence was in a room
where someone told me what to do and
provide it for me yeah why should I have
to figure out how to make food that's
what I want nailed it yeah that's why
all these college kids come out and
they're like communism the authorities
you know it's crazy though well I think
the general idea of communism can only
be bred from children from the immature
it's a better way to put a children is
just me doing an emotional dig at these
people cuz I think that yeah yeah so I
think one of the things we see with
Millennials is that they never feel like
they're ready to take over and the best
example of this is our three or four 70
year old 80 year old presidential
figures tulsi gabbard awesome a people
to judge awesome Andrew yang awesome
he's in his 30s right late thirties butI
judge yeah yeah yep buddy judge didn't
tell so you're both like 37 13 yang is
what in his 40s that's what we need
younger boy Lee younger me it's fair to
say we have a decent mount up local
candidates you know who were younger
yeah but I think because of how
Millennials view themselves their
children that not everybody like you
know clearly you know not us and not
probably people watching to be honest
yeah but a lot of them do they've never
grown up they've never become adults
mm-hmm they don't want to
more important definitely yeah zero
interest it's a way easier scary one
grandpa Bernie to take care of yeah
Bernie Bernie Bernie is like I'm going
to picture dinner for you I'm gonna pay
for your school I'm gonna grab your ice
cream you know my whole life has been
man you're so right about that that's
true yeah I've got to figure out how
look dude we have a garden in the back
yeah where we grew up we grew radishes
we have radishes ice we've carats of
child that's the crazy the craziest
thing
whoo what was that sketch I don't have
ever seen it where it's his British dude
and he's like he like looks over in sign
of Cameron he goes hey hey you want to
hear way to get rich quick check it out
I got these seeds right put him in the
ground yes it put some water on them
food grows up you can sell it it grows
right out of the ground just like that
you'll get to anything and it's like has
someone ever seen yes have these young
people ever realized that but they're so
used to in my opinion things being given
to them that they don't have a concept
of how to make create source or be
independent yeah and so they're not and
so they need someone to do things for
them it's like have you ever solved a
problem on your own and haven't and now
you think about what our last subject
about the SJW clickbait be things that
everyone's spreading around on internet
and it's like that's reaffirming their
beliefs that they're owed stuff that
they they should get all this stuff yeah
so it's just this whole cycle is just
never-ending and getting worse and worse
and worse it is it's a problem of human
like it's like just human nature it's
the cycle it's like Unilever owns both
dove and Ben and Jerry's exam dove does
the real beauty campaign where it's like
you can be overweight it's no big deal
and then there are other properties ice
cream they're like eat more ice cream
and they also own like the lactose
medicine yeah you just sell it in one
pack you know why you know I always
thought that we drink coke sodas with
our big macs and fries why because
you're eating a big pile of garbage and
slogging up your system so you need a
psychoactive stimulant to get you back
to feeling normal I think about it yeah
that's true well it's like a burger is
trash and you eat it and you're like I
feel terrible let me take my caffeine
which is a psychoactive stimulant very
similar similar to cocaine and we drink
a gallon of it and then you [ __ ]
handled anything now
he makes you euphoric it makes it
enhances muscle endurance makes you less
tired so you eat trash and then drug
yourself to feel better that's like
that's just like the people gotta eat
better dude that's a whole nother
surprise it's an example of how you know
glutton culture expands and comes to
this point where you literally have
people who are morbidly obese and
unhealthy being told by the media it's
okay to be morbidly obese and unhealthy
and eat trash you're beautiful you're
being oppressed actually you take no
responsibility for your health
mm-hm and look I'll tell you what here's
what I always I always clarify if you
know the risks and choose to do it I
don't care but if you if you think you
have no responsibility for your own
health and then demand I pay for your
healthcare yeah perfect example of these
people mmm-hmm dude let me go out into
the woods with a dog I'll build my own
log cabin leave me alone you people have
lost your minds and they just don't want
to work and it's like they just dragged
everybody down that's probably one of
the most like you're gonna be like oh
man Tim's going crazy read to law
look at a certain point what what's the
saying if you're not liberal when you're
young you have no heart heart and if
you're not conservatively older you have
no head brain yeah brain well head is
better it's like you know but it's not
even it's not even about that I think I
think that saying comes from the fact
that when these young people finally get
their first paycheck and see how much
taxes they had to give away they're like
what why things are asking questions
that's a red pill how much of my money
went to killing kids Oh No thank you
wait I got to pay for that guy's health
care he's smoking a pack a day yeah come
on man you know and eating McDonald's
every meal dude I feel like chug in the
coca-cola it's the best it's the best
way to like you know these young people
haven't experienced someone refusing to
take responsibility and then demanding
they cover for them yeah that's a good
point because they're the ones
constantly demanding
person it's getting really bad to the
point where like you have these these
kids in schools where you might argue
you ever be in we're ever in a lab where
the partner and the lab partner did no
work oh yeah and you're like and we're
gonna fail unless you help it's like go
do whatever you're like on and you end
up doing all the work I have no doubt
that'll turn you into a young
conservative for sure but now the kids
were just complaining the teachers they
shouldn't have to do it at all and
they're calling teachers racist and he's
just like okay I'm sorry class is
cancelled
all right you Olga days yep yeah they're
literally doing that and they're arguing
they're arguing now with their dogma
that like teachers should give better
grades for like diversity and inclusion
and wait wait you didn't we're
cancelling you yeah yeah and the
students will straight up candidates
happened right you know Brett Weinstein
it's like one of the funniest stories is
that they started spreading lies about
him and he's like a progressive lefty
guy and so he's like some people
approached him I can represent it would
happen but they were calling him like a
bigot a racist and then he actually
started arguing for them like saying
it's it's you know humans have inherent
bigotry and racism where it's because we
I don't wanna I don't wanna put words in
his mouth but basically the ideas I
understand it is humans have a tendency
to feel safer around things that are
familiar so they look for people who
look like them so if you try very hard
to break down our inherent biases and
they're like what but you're that you're
the you're the white supremacist like
these our brains go just broke yeah but
but you know the fun image yeah there's
a lot there's a lot of complain about I
guess we just a random rant today huh
yeah whatever because here we are now
with everything locked down and it all
it all stems from you know it's just
it's it's I feel I feel kind of sad it's
like you lose a friend to a cult you
know they say feels like they say things
that clearly make no sense and when you
try talking ohm like listen let me just
ask you one question the government
should provide the food where does the
food come from the farmers from the
government I know but like the governor
has to get the food from somewhere right
right yeah well they they just have it
like you what's your answer from the
farmers okay where do the farmers get
their resources to make the food like
you said dude the food just grows out of
the ground yeah yeah who puts it there
yeah pulls it out who
actually doing it fried on the truck
right they actually have like automatic
trucks like tractors now that like drive
and do it themselves pretty cool but
charged those trucks that's the real
argument for you beyond my opinion
that's why I like Andrew yang Automation
is a real argument like what happens
when the factories are totally automated
that's a good point that the farms are
granted we're not there yet but we are
heading there certainly yeah so this is
why you know I asked these questions
because I don't think I think the
biggest challenge from going from our
current capitalistic system to a
post-scarcity system should we ever it's
the middle period where there's a hybrid
of it is one of the things I brought up
on the Rogan PAC podcast last month
we're gonna end up with a period where
there's people who have to work and
people who can't you know what happens
when 90 percent of your population
doesn't have to work and ten percent
does kind of like what we're seeing with
essential workers you know people have
to go out and do all this hard work
while we get a six hundred dollar bonus
for not working that's exactly what's
happening them in the balls you know
like you work for Less yeah we are gonna
watch video you know watch TV and play
video games for the next two months and
get extra money to do it yeah yeah
vastra money thing is like part of the
problem but either way it's like could
you imagine living in a society where
you had a serf class that had to do the
labor or while you didn't it's like The
Hunger Games yeah
does feeling I understand it's quite
honorable we're like we're gonna have
you know ubi and we're gonna get to that
point where everybody is free never
gonna happen bro you they're all heroes
for working good job heroes I'm gonna go
back to watching my youtube videos
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you